cham
interviews myself basically she wheelies
picture of project manager at talk
about the next minute the
presentation made the performance juli korn
with we thought we are going to laughter
lounge of the protect source project herself
basically she did a business translation
because of you do something like the
factory  important that i always on to
know translate uhs i management rod is
basically do in the background of
systems starts in the beginning of last
year to date up at the event started
quaid design system trivago because
frontend let's say the historical and I
had some issues that  takes you later
tobi enterprise ihe still would have
created the the spirit that the trainer
knows you the task force created to end
task force one man's later the important
for you project reset flowed
innside by how would that is like the
newspaper tuttosport first of all  it will
import almost like Herbert of
applications like music like hip hop or
with is the trivago hotel cert wilkens
will be spoiler old hotel europa league
either lot of other
applications and lots of different
department of is it won in leipzig
in palma and in amsterdam and  like never
had consistent style guide design system
of course am inconsistent code and
design one other important
giant baby this project was to
improve quality and maintain ability to
let the example current bielecki and
quality superdome like kost also in the new
system design system and increases and of
course  i want to be faster in building
modern sustainable user interfaces for
our products as i said i starts
developing creating peter lambert
trivago and we've always on our corp
the day before with business critical to the test
as to work centered design development
process leike tomic design is  much more
efficiently sets company pages
when it said it
14 this wants combination on average on that
night and want to have the page book
saturday lottery composed was
basically barry peace and our company
and assessing mixture from the bronx like
a buffer frameworks basically back and
dad  says it to better
it is what the first sight will be like
monsters of september the back and for
the perfect but you can't see sepsis
townscape will design thinking would have to
tomic design changes just put external
websites of courage as far as we as a
table to do  sees how the science buddys
screens have a consistent
design this year coming back to our core
products trivago starts them and off
2011 first time open text css celebrates
hard there in Katowice we started to
produce and the city in the cs smz-ost
basically electro call it  the city that
happens if you don't have design system
system and trust open file and select
the bottom of fire the work center
calls words so basically here also
application looked like system you
asked at the end of 2011 as before as came to
2011 started to  create better way to
face lift off the website like at apple
to improve code is not having design
systems is what you do but on ms project
related to conversion way treated in
2014 15 cent and conversion bicc dose
looks at least a bit
modern because in 2015
like  picture of an adaptive on the scale
basically would have desktop förster percent
uhwiesen resource manager resources and
able to do a completely picture sony where
able to do is basically mobile and
desktop page kibiz is super big wall
to basically body dead 2 4 down the
sword as snappy as  before started this
is how you look like you remember this
way we showed you before this that much
better you horny simons of you that more
bodies it wants the autumn pink since
the beginning of the end of the world as
we had a specific looks like starting  to
go up here but if you have been they
start out but the peaks because
this might be 6 is electric here in the
beginning of the state is already source
to have to wait a place for mobility and
scalability office space so basically
over here  as well as the able to the bone
and president would have small capital it
is but coldplays which would like to
show you know what we build basically
frankenstein to 11
itself but it remains designs
pride with space to be better than head of
sales management director side up
would be
us  can a lot of alcohol desktops
critical
the icons videos
this lot of the decade with travel time
to remove train stations icon centers workout
like also had some people in the box for
example is present from our politicians
department fought michael kuester
household is over you have a
renaissance is it  fetching process
crashes cost it was said to be too complex and
you today the cathedral and structures the
baby the guests the upper hand again like
the new photos of jesse hughes troll
basically it's what wooden stairs it was said
it would be happy to let you person kempke's
village in 1 1 internet  explorer hesse
limit inspectors reebok it and so are
watching and asset how would have desktop
first thought you might not especially
mobile device first has to the
desktops partially removed ableist mobile
star from topic witches of course i shot
cupid mobile first to basic ran first
mobile styles  the desktop starter without
playback samples leaves the said we had
in consistency and the missing
style guide
now found basically everyone happy
with what they could look like how css
chair tour ends world tools to show
for example people what about to
understand the people how did he
overlay  complex smc s and don structure
coming back to protect the basic i had
to decide the his team is also
engineering team how to protect and how
to explain the management fleet
management tlm rbi human factors could i
have to make it more transparent what
you get me  you are some say we came up
with three steps that cost on site for his
project
christoph becker steps we had to do to
review the witcher basically creative
lab one thing is still had we said css
code and especially reset cssr be heard
that again that matter  in fixing
if you stayed browsers and wood as well as
used content box and one of europe plc
assessment of use content box basic
leasing you have like paclet volks ampel
view just browser zoom center browsers
you have the cheeky late service of the
border and have spent the case  of use
enormous performance this thing to explore
the stakeholder the word crisis mobile
first suite robert boers list password
rbb has werr will be a sweet forest
basically very easy to explain the third
place to be mobile first to replace him
is great because they say never let me
sign end in advance formed people don't
change the existing layout despite
basically has challenge because the view
of the year is the notebook or changes
that but he couldn't because we would
have we had an impact because I never
change we have just live retail  things
button color can can lead to flash
converter on the example of Amazon don't
know how often the test victory everyone on whether
they stay on the Techart button Hessin
Fuentes so Boeing would have in
the architecture us out ending you the
prince of this time we can  give you some
more technical details what i basically
would you have but the sts essebsi 50001 of
code is like head of course i spg is
how did you have jane seymour
to remove she paints glass called o2 world
of possible and changing the appearance
to reduce the complexity in  they set
harmful see like in the ghetto kid
support relieved like kurt f cell
future is what would have captured
support at the cis point important
boxee box half the time frame
the risk of technical people to
understand why you have basically
constant space and from the time to  time
life would have been through factoring basically
force one of our challenges to explain
the management fleet feature freeze dual
as well as four background to you core
products scale hotels working as think
about trade people see it right to
build features and trust of our users
and to basic i have  to say i has the top
four weeks because of the factors and
space is the concerto management thinks
vw is good so wood is a classic there is
a new project on whether she is gone
learning centers porta built
q-cells are user management
just set understand  what would you do i do
it for the evaluation of display
consistent but case it is up to the city
that may be does not initially have 50
sms is North Korean to something
supplemented case is just like faster than
people will love you to try to be faster
his posted very much like Germany
had bit of watchdog in
but new existence the people get sick
full liter and all very important Luca
Toni's ink technology should so understand the
third person servers demanded just can't
go then Tony Iommi come up with respect
yourself do to  understand that important
that the company is money entholzer
half sink wittler business
processing potatoes and interesting
talent for the car
especially imports is there and it but
the set and have sex is in process and
don't stop losing something with a very
important car dealer management
expectation  especially asset management
kenneth klev things like the fact the
great and very happy few ken gibson
update every day is worked out of work
out to play mmo s ms tablet crisis
best and maybe you and i think we
just do to access the work out one thing
that people process which was very
important that what about having process
of the processor moore last people the
time home awaits
romy very important commitment over
estimation lately anti-virus molly
factoring the child almost blows apse like
factoring test in small but as the
people the better visibility  as well as salt
on the splitting off wars at last read
the bishops' conference asks Liebert and
ticket system time because it's very
hard fact that won't you very hard user
interface because you had so much
dependency battle los angeles electro
here a good trip informed what more
important than the technical support act
has a know set people are committed
to that I want to get it done as fast as
possible to create a possible you're
interested justin long tax and asset
management as well as have internal social
ksv on 3 update the people and  side
hedia we well in time and very important
that one point where we didn't how
come you have to use your hand is specially
for the finest is for us a widget
first problem means offers the band with
connections because if you like for
johannes to the people  are the new
president of the NOK there are only problems with
the Lakers team is motivated people and
let there be awesome is not about
special effects projects from we forget
to be for is not about my key management
people
controlling people is about what people
and difficult explained  that are coming
back tour tour for mom's process a
people we had this post basically but
can you go there instead of having to what
ever be used cars on energy and the
search for mathias hain l 222 visual
process which have thought it simple and
coming to protect  him the kof system
basically no counters developers
designers to create people and the other
supporters so basically back and tax
justice has to be done in the same horn
distributes release and any and of course
the performance of very happy ending to
know in power performance put
insiders like  hefty june was able to do these
processes as well as head of the meeting and
seventeen stand up center you can murder
as a basic i needed to music and outcomes
and we have some numbers to see what
the basic element that was nine hundred
things we do incredible des babys partly
goalkeeper or less  like to talk swan
college on main event watch conference
interested parties with something that they
said no beer are they office bust
committing tutower feature brings
thorsten also smashing could know the
support and most basically committing
and contributing to the project and if
I had I would have stopped mine  playlist
gaming series finally a can do
of code
javascript and had to cssb is the lines
of code of 25 percent of the asc space
and replace the existing icon service
which you can use with of course a too
much amazing to the hundred acre wood
christina user interface bad but the
saints of my different ways  to you
don't have any impact on and conversion
negative impact on conversion also like
change would end to files
dancing stars of the ssc lektor as before
the iss select fund again that
it is probably like before 1 estg knows the
fair reduce on coming  back to
use on Saturday a highlight for
basically first was the desktops applied
sciences oberwirt mcquarrie from mobile
devices and inconsistent wars how do
you get them mobile stylesheet a
complete history click to basic changing
horses and positive impact on and
racing performance the topic is get what
you pay  to play version bettina
most retina display will time until the
norm is wide and eight before
requests games wide
we can take as ossis 126 from the
after what we saw at the colors like
tablet introduce the color palette
trivago lux 0 exists on legacy code
in  bad ems in operation picture new from the 9th
picture franziska ballet and how should
it be a chaos as well as the hessen-spd icon
set will be like news and can easily be sent to
people who cost it de facto too
very positive will be better overview of
which were used to end  will that be very
difficult if I had before and after you
like basic thinking about the foundation
of a completely god in vom supertalent
is basically broadway basically you
mobile first you know you have them
come components like like to do a b
testing value on course dual speed test
is it like that is the presence of the
user space education and 50 percent to
much magic basically what you see here
is something is significantly negative
indication is different matthew campbell
imagine that for example with that
people search or trivago look at the
advertiser and sent buchsi  hotels first
medical hot saw some other things like
build second session duration witcher
import fast and something cost boss
new talent it was also expected to
the event with crazy on that's it corners
June could longboard changing has to be
unicorn the osi office offers the
unicorns  and twitter account sales
big project ends giving you some
of which is refactoring project like
bild.de foundation to move right to the
next level with roger moore business of
areas basically but foundation is
much more stable relieved ovations
men example the very end of mine
presentation how could it be better if
performance on mobile rich wars episode
i costs lotteries something around 550
million will not really like but at
least like cookies and especially box
will like ethanol devices disappeared and
all things very important that we have
much better understanding of power user
interface works photo mig designers and
white christmas is important and prices do
you love well know how coldplay
keyboard in building new web pages
he is but the satin optimal design
development process and be introduced a
lot of you guidelines css bento css
coming to move it pastor you  time after
sales business critical elements like
coliseum element itself the ott version
until it is stable 1 in between systems and
i can't see is super class is the
but price it is here content is not
what really user friendly motor show the
next one nine months  to develop and the
dead end after we moved to sees willi
peter lapp holding like bild in east and
human services testing of developing
prototyping inside the pattern matching
with lily cole started singh like the
business metvix which started
longines new elements that present
integrated what the conversion  19 percent
but the cross eyed possum much more
modules and much more structure like wait
to do incredible almost September
basically days of work out to maintain
the date of design kallas basic and ever
wanted to mars return to basics in the
business week which was just positive
is as old as factoring we belong to sec